walk him to this video playing eyes wide
shut from Norway nope from Denmark I'm
sorry just a bit too quick i know the
flag hey sorry if to all Danish people
and Norwegians I was just it was just a
slip okay the fraud hmm yeah let's try
something else jadon term have something
great ready against the comfort zone and
try to vary with the different lines oh
this does not look look too bad and
maybe this wasn't some precise you know
you know yeah german word exactly is
what i was trying to say if i now take
with the ponies got to check in very
very annoying wow yeah so I Epona suit
some very bad from structural point of
view oh we didn't give the check now
this is surprising ok don't mind no I
like it I have a very stable center and
um it's not so clear where is this
players
i meani five is not easy to accomplish
especially after there should be six and
so I have a 5b seven as a weakness ok
now I can just take it and play play the
Queen attending attending a five this is
some not so you did this position yep
but now it's very unstable a five is
threatened how do you protect all this
hmm now I've got rook be one okay wait
wait wait wait not so quick this rook
hmm there's also Bishop d3 just just a
moment this looks like there is some
some technical problem really this is a
good move anyway this is a good move
anyway the bishop this has done this job
and this is nicely this is a good move
to dislodge the Queen what about D 5 D 5
Knight takes hmm my techs still as
possible if I play rook here it's going
to play 95 maybe and take p7 if I go
rook here inside this would have the
benefit of covering a form keeping this
covered but 95 queen bee seven does Roxy
one unfortunately bit of a nasty trick
ok I'm going to do this one it's ok
hmm I didn't even see that hmm ok well
it's not the end of the world but I
still didn't see it I didn't see that
this was lying ok so I'm activating the
night here yeah he's got the a poem but
I have an active rook check check the
only ok now is addressing this exact
problem the only issue who also black
that the bishop slop playing mmm d 5 is
this is the sir this could be too
ambitious
okay I still want to try to to do
something in this game not allowing a
simple simple draw okay night see for
coming maybe maybe I can do something
here f4f 493 back where it's very
ambitious maybe maybe too ambitious
nothing I don't have enough time to
really really do something do something
where some consideration does need to
play good moves
now you can take and take on g3 no I
have throat g6 okay at least hmm Jim
what the heck did i do here what have I
done to deserve this yeah check I know I
deserve it but what have I done
check check yeah this did this does not
really help him too much g3 maybe sir
yeah maybe that's a I think it's okay
again unless I'm I'm really overlooking
something something drastic
check check nights your form it's not
the greatest trick ever check check I've
ok to coming time morning Jim I could
have just taken Jack was much easier
check check check check Queenie 5
through a check
check check I can just promote what the
heck I don't have time here Christ check
check maybe it's the drone check no no
I'm winning check check check mate whoa
wow another frankenstein' game weights
right out of our movie what the heck
what did i do at the end here I really I
really don't know check check check
check I really forgot that you can
simply promote but this actually do this
yeah geez this is a forced mate that's
that's cute I didn't see that it was
just a coincidence it's it's it's really
a first mate how is it a false mate if
he is going Jackie's going yeah this is
it this is a direct made of course ah
what there he goes here how is this amid
Channing d3 ah this is really nice him
yeah check me what the game what a game
yeah well you need to fight I mean at
least i'm a bit lucky at the moment the
recent games i was playing badly and and
unlucky at the same time this is not a
good combination so yeah let's just book
this under under you need some luck
sometimes and go to the next game thanks
for watching